[Music]
i have with me david pakman
he is a progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david patman show and i wanted to
talk to david pakman
he is
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about here
[Music]
there are males most men today yeah
male 1 they think and act like a woman
they are emotional
they are mentally armed they have no
logic
and that's a major male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse well we gotta
that's a lot that's a lot you know agree
with everything that's raw
abortion they think and act just like a
woman a beta male died
but another baby doesn't because he is a
logical thinking
and then controlled by the darkness of
david pacman
he is
[Music]
he is
[Music]
david he is a baby
david pacman he is a player
you're not here to communicate i really
appreciate you coming out i'm going to
let you go it's a waste of time to talk
to you
we're not communicating you're acting
like a because you're asking bizarre
questions you're actually like
and you're wasting my time i appreciate
you coming all right
goodbye goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
that is the new and updated introduction
uh we've got some new clips in there
and it's all very very exciting i'm
gonna be very
honest with you guys i have no idea what
if anything we are going to be seeing
today
um there was an event scheduled in
pennsylvania to be attended by both
donald trump and rudy giuliani as well
as others
about voter freud as some call it
voter fraud as others call it
anyway someone got coronavirus
we actually don't know who at this point
in time so we know
that trump i guess is no longer going to
this thing we had a tweet
um recently from caitlin collins saying
trump's planned trip to pennsylvania is
off after a member of the campaign
tested positive
excuse me tested positive we don't yet
know
who that individual is or whether
there is any all right what was that
where did that come from oh here it is
oh okay so there is an event let's see
mike jones i'm trying to see who it is
so okay there is an event we don't know
exactly who's going to be at this event
but pennsylvania is still having an
event
um today related to um
to freud i guess it's going to be
freudian in nature
and um we we're going to be following it
very very closely
but we don't yet know who all is going
to be here we don't know if rudy rudy
giuliani is going to be here
this feed is monitoring the white house
of course and then we have
a right side broadcasting feed as well
so we'll keep it here for the time being
we'll we'll be muted i have
so much to talk to you guys about and i
am going to be
reading super chats john person just
said release the pacman because i'm at
an undisclosed location for thanksgiving
the super chats don't show up on the
screen but but
everybody on youtube still sees them and
i see them so i'm glad to take super
chats
ralph says what up deepak that's a great
super chat
very exciting and um jane
says she can't stay but we'll re-watch
later so we don't know what we have
waiting for us today
but it is going to be something now
there's all sorts of news that i do want
to get to
i have troy york and prickles guy
voicemails to play i have one new song
we have the news of the tragic death
of argentinian soccer superstar diego
armando maralona and we could review
maybe his two famous goals in all of
history that's something else i would be
willing to look at with you guys
um maybe we'll just do that real quick
just to just to get that
get that going argentina football legend
diego maradona
dies at 60. um
matthias morla maradona's longtime agent
confirmed to efe
the world cup winner was recently
hospitalized and underwent brain surgery
was released on november
11th the argentine football association
released a statement through its
president claudio tapia
saying it expresses its deepest pain at
the death of our legend
diego armando maradona you'll always be
in our hearts
maradona won the 86 world cup with
argentina played for barcelona at the
club level as well as napoli
whom he helped lead to the serie a title
reportedly of a heart attack
in recovery from the brain surgery
not the healthiest guy for a very long
time
and we have a couple of videos that we
can review here
this is the infamous hand of god goal
where he is accused
accused of using his hand to score
i don't know about that let's take a
look at it the wide men
have found little space in this contest
[Music]
there it is and in
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't know guys i mean let's let's
even look at it in slow motion
playback speed 0.25
the left hand is going up there
i think that was a clean header guys i
don't know i i
you know it might be because i'm
argentinian that i'm saying that
but uh i think he was just blocking the
sun with that hand or something like
that
i'm also an idiot here is uh maybe one
of his
most famous goals evading and avoiding
you know basically all of the defenders
take a look at this
[Applause]
isn't that the best
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway so very very sad news uh the
death
of uh of of a superhero in my country
uh diego armando maradona so very very
sad
and uh we may or may not have more
coverage of that in the future i
really don't know um but uh
rest in peace and there's an interesting
series on netflix where he's coaching a
mexican team more recently
and um he seems to be high the entire
uh series it's really sad actually
but there there it is okay we are
standing by for a voter fraud
hearing in pennsylvania originally
scheduled to be attended by donald trump
um but uh he will not be going because
someone has
corvid we don't exactly know who
um a few other super chats coming in um
ac asking whether i'm canvassing with
steven destiny banel in georgia i am not
i'm not flying around right now because
of the virus
but i did appear on destiny's stream
late last night as i was brushing my
teeth getting ready to go to bed
and i may we may do some live streaming
where i will stream
while destiny is down in georgia um
other super chats coming in shane says
using this moment to teach you science
baking soda in your brine
will denature the proteins in turkey
skin making it crispy when you cook it
important message for people making a
turkey justin says would like to see a
behind the scenes of your tech setup at
home
uh mike software you're using for
broadcast yeah so that that setup i'm
not i'm not at home right now i'm at
another i'm in what's called the bunker
it's a family location very strong
bunker
but what i have here as a backup setup
is an evr e20 my old
mic mic arm same camera i use in the
main studio
a little portable light and just like a
two monitor setup so it's
it's a pretty pretty simple setup here
joseph points out cnn said trump is not
going to be at this event yeah
so we we recently heard that because of
someone testing positive for coronavirus
we are not going to be seeing donald
trump at this event
uh we don't know exactly who we will be
seeing
at this event now did the video freeze
this guy looks very still
it looks like the video may be frozen
oh no it's not wow that guy is just
sitting as still as i've ever seen a
human
be that's interesting yeah weird
um so anyway we're standing by for all
of this scheduled for the bottom of the
hour
i want to say some thanks to people
signing up over on twitch
thanks to kiros and a danish joint
as well as stellar legacy the great
poudini
yikes um k dizzle nada amenzor
and suffer ruth all of these folks uh
signing up over on twitch which i very
much appreciate
uh and also a big thank you to sven aka
johansen
sven aka johansen who just signed up at
joinpakman.com
and his new member number one look at
that it's just just a little tiny sliver
of blue there which is very very
exciting
uh alright it looks like this event is
continuing to move forward
a couple of other things to get to i do
have one new song that i want to play
for you guys
this is a a song of a jimmy from philly
phone call we've never had this before
this is from christian audet who i
believe produced this song
in nigeria just take a listen to this uh
let's see
uh oh you know who's on hold jimmy from
philly
the uh angry gardener or landscaper who
leaves
like 10 voicemails a night is on the
phone i'm curious what's maybe he can
explain to us what he's doing jimmy
what's going on
david can you hear me we can hear you
fine yeah i didn't see any genitalia i
my eyes saw him in and my ears
heard of me okay so how is that
disgusting for me to make that
true observation i don't see how that's
disgusting now the card before i made a
couple
literary remarks but i did not let me
ask you something just as i have you on
the phone
when you're gonna call in like five
times in a row
near midnight eastern time are you
probably
drinking david you have been drinking
yourself and twitch is such a piece of
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
post a message i mean are you kidding me
yeah it was just oh my god after five
minutes i just
i thought it was hilarious all right but
david here here's your here's my real
question oh
why don't you guys why are you gonna
discuss
um
[Music]
so there it is a jimmy from philly call
going uh go going desperately wrong and
very very quickly
might i add and then i do have a couple
new voice mails to play for you guys
this is uh this is troy york calling in
with another screed
telling about your video on kaylee
mcnamee and uh mcnamee
what is with you and kyle kalinski you
guys always like attacking
tomy lehern tell me lay hearn
who is that kaylee mcnamee mcnamee
it's just like something with you guys
think conservative hot looking women
like
i don't know are you guys like radical
homosexuals like don lemon or
uh basically are you just upset you
can't get a hot looking woman like uh
kaylee mcnamee and you write why and
attack her
i i always thought kyle was the
spineless little dick licker
[ __ ] wonder who always attacked
conservative women
and what she often does on his stupid
show but
i was really surprised at you know seem
to be doing that as well
what would uh what this what i was about
to say with jimmy from philly this is
troy york though
whoa interesting mask i've never seen
that let this is an interesting he's
like wearing like a tube
um what what troy doesn't seem to
understand
it's not that we're going after
attractive conservative women
it's that we just go after bad ideas
regardless of the attractiveness or
gender of the person who is
uh issuing the bad idea it's that simple
are you having like sexual issues or
anger problems because you can't uh uh
uh get a woman like kaylee mcnamee
left idiot and uh
you know what i don't understand uh
you know donald trump's not going to uh
allow this election flaw to
continue you talk about michigan how
after she came on they certified this
what do you say
what do you fail to say was the reason
the michigan you had
two or three republicans who switched uh
uh anyway so as you can see that's like
insanely boring and that i have one
one other voicemail something about
sexual assault let me listen to this
hey david pakman we know that you
committed a felonious sexual assault act
on a person under the age of 13 years
ago we will be putting you on blast on
social networks this week okay so
there's that uh yeah
this is this has happened before where
i've heard from people who say
david you know if you're all about uh
investigate allegations and all this
stuff we'll show you how easy it is
um to make false allegations we're going
to
make allegations of sexual assault
against you
and some some people actually tried
calling newspapers claiming that i had
committed a sexual assault and it went
nowhere because obviously they were
false allegations and it completely
backfired that's actually a story from a
couple
i guess about a year it's from the
kavanaugh era um
and you know it just it was like a
complete self-own
it it was uh auto cuckoldry i guess is
what i would call it really wild wild
stuff
um okay so we're caught up on voicemails
oh i i have one more
troy york voicemail that i've not
pre-screened are you guys interested in
hearing it
i've not listened to it so it really
could be anything um
i don't know if that's something people
want to take a quick listen to before we
move on to other things
i don't know if it's prickly sky
i don't know that i have anything from
prickles guy let me see
prickless guy no i don't this is the
troy this is a new troy york
track fresh off the presses
oh whoops hold on a second i muted i
muted this let me unmute
and then we will go back to the
beginning here we go
hey david pac-man this is troy york uh
this one let you know that president
trump
had a briefing uh the dell has gone over
30
000 the doll what is that like like
like the indian dish dal is that lentils
i think la
dal is lentils in indian he had a doll
briefing that's weird
despite the attempts by the democrats in
the far left
to wreck the economy to use this
pandemic over hyping
to destroy our will and morals uh
i just want to say that you keep
referring to joe biden
as president and uh no i'm referring to
him as president-elect
i'm not referring to him as president
he's not the president i wouldn't do
something so stupid
well i got two words about joe biden um
that you have to remember uh about his
supposedly election
and how he's bringing these same
retreads out from uh
british troops administrations it's
disgraceful thinking
john kerry and janet yellen and uh you
know this old skull this [ __ ]
scarecrow this this ugly walking corpse
this [ __ ] face from hell this this
[ __ ] great hair
dictator this this how triggered huh i
mean it's just it's amazing these people
are so
so triggered that uh donald uh that
donald trump
and and his incompetent selections are
are quickly going out i mean it's that
simple they're going out and we're just
putting in you know they could be people
we disagree with on some political
issues but they're just normal people
people not lunatic extremist ideologues
and by the way
um here is donald trump he did a 46
second press
conference yesterday check this out this
is so pathetic
well thank you very much and i just want
to congratulate everybody
the stock market dow jones industrial
average just hit 30 000.
by the way who is he congratulating hi i
just want to congratulate everybody
the dow hit 30 000. who's the
congratulations for which is the highest
in history
we've never broken 30 000 and that's
just despite
everything that's taken place with the
pandemic i'm very
uh thrilled with what's happened on the
vaccine front that's been
absolutely incredible it's nothing like
that has
ever happened medically and i think
people are acknowledging that
and it's having a big effect but the
stock market's just
broken thirty thousand never been broken
that number that's a sacred number
thirty what does he mean
sacred what's sacred about that that's
bizarre
two thousand nobody thought they'd ever
see it that's the ninth time
since uh the beginning of 2020
and it's the 48th time that we've
broken records in during the
trump administration and i just want to
congratulate all the people within the
administration that worked so hard
and most importantly i want to
congratulate the people of our country
right because there are no people like
you thank you very much everybody very
strong public appearance and then hold
on john kerry
there's this other clip speaking of john
kerry
um this is a really good thing maybe
we'll get to this a little bit later
uh but not not quite yet so i know
people are telling me that this meeting
that we have live video of has been
cancelled
what has been can all we know so far is
trump was expected to be here and trump
won't be here because someone tested
positive for the virus and we don't yet
know who
but the meeting does appear to be going
on there are people in the room already
and we are standing by it's scheduled
scheduled to start
in about five minutes give me your milk
please has subscribed with twitch prime
and says love the show david when will
you have destiny
on again i don't know i was on with
destiny for about 45 minutes last night
and maybe that's something destiny will
be posting um
to his uh youtube channel we've got a
few other
super chats coming in robert mugabe says
that wasn't a handball you're watching
too much
trump my guy rubbing off on you dan of
earth says love how pence looks like a
marionette doll
yabbitz asks do i believe secret service
agents are safe regarding biden harris
than the white house the metrics would
be interesting best of all to the family
um best to all the family yeah i assume
so because
biden and harris are being less
irresponsible
vosh is here oh wow look vosh coming in
with a strong super chat howdy howdy my
dude hope you're well
my fans enjoyed our talk very fun
talking with a liberal
who actually knows what socialism is and
enjoy
thanksgiving wow it's great to hear from
vaush
and um it was great having having him on
uh somebody told me just to refer to him
as ian that
ian is his real name but i think that
that was just somebody egging me on
uh but great to see vosh and uh best of
luck to everybody from the standpoint of
thanksgiving keep it safe i will be
doing just a uh
i'm gonna be involved in just like a
food exchange
my girlfriend and i are making a couple
dishes and then different people are
making different
dishes and we're just exchanging them in
uh
from from in an outdoor setting and
everybody will kind of make their own
you know reheating these various dishes
that will be made by people so that's
going to be that
we're not expecting not expecting too
much else
we are standing by here for a press
briefing about voter freud
and we don't know who's going to be here
donald trump reportedly cancelling his
appearance
at this hearing because somebody tested
positive for
coronavirus i want to say thanks to
johanna
krumholz who's new member number two
today
and laura p who is new member number
three
i do want to make just a uh this is
going to be a very
polite and limited appeal to everybody
um over the last 10 days we have had
more people cancel memberships than in
any previous 10-day period
because of what's going on economically
because of job losses
because of what's going on financially
for a lot of people
so if you are in that situation do not
get a membership
in fact i will be furious with you if
you get a membership
do not do that i don't want anybody's
last dollar
if you are in a position where you can
you're in the privileged position of
being able to support
independent media that you like with a
couple bucks a month
grab a membership at joinpakman.com as
you can see above my head we have a
brand new coupon code
fresh start all one word all lower case
even though it looks like all caps there
that's confusing but
in any case maybe all caps also works
all lowercase all caps whatever
that saves you 70 off joe biden
reportedly will make that
heavy of a discount illegal so i would
take advantage of the discount code now
those may be against the law once uh
president elect biden is sworn in and
every time somebody signs up the blue
bar starts to fill up which is
incredible and um i i will thank
everybody on stream which is which is
wild
which is wild uh okay
let's see what else we have going on i
see a lot of people asking me for my
thoughts on thanksgiving
i'm going to be totally frank with you i
don't think thanksgiving
dishes are that good i i really don't
um i think hanukkah dishes are much
better a nice hanukkah brisket i mean
what's better than that
if you say look you can have a
slow-cooked 10-hour brisket
or turkey come on guys
come on uh you know you don't have uh
you don't have to be american and i'm
not
to understand that that is a very very
easy
easy choice um you know mashed potatoes
i'm not big on we already ranted about
pie
last week it's like pie come on guys pie
um so anyway yeah i don't i'm not that
big of a fan of any of the dishes really
um you know sweet potatoes i love sweet
potatoes
with the marshmallow give me a break
brown sugar
you're turning the sweet potato which is
a perfect vegetable
into candy essentially and i know that
i'm being called a communist for uh
expressing these these ideas absolutely
not i
i am resisting that octos alias
says 45 short press conference likely an
act of attrition to ceos who pressured
him to let the transition continue
that may be zachary thomas agrees with
me brisket all the way
i mean listen there's people who want me
to go further into
the um turkey versus brisket thing
it's no contest what is there to even go
into brisket versus turkey come on
come on guys it's ridiculous uh big
thank you to alexan angiano
who is new member number four today and
emmanuel
egwu who is new member number five
at joinpakman.com um for people just
joining me and telling me that the press
conference is canceled
we are watching the press conference
right now
you understand people coming in saying
david you're an idiot this is cancelled
it's on our screen right now it's about
to start what we've learned is that due
to someone testing
positive donald trump is not going to be
here
and we don't know whether uh rudy
giuliani
is going to be here uh but that is that
bing is calling for thanksgiving
chilpino
jose says his puppy was born on election
day
edward appreciates my views and blunt
honesty
ant and sharon say happy thanksgiving
david and
shalom shalom baron
says i couldn't agree with you more
about thanksgiving um
very strong stance on sweet potatoes
make sweet potatoes vegetables again
yeah you know somebody somebody told i'm
not going to say who it is i don't want
to out them
they made this a sweet potato dish
where you take like it's only like three
or four sweet potatoes
and you put a half cup of brown sugar on
them
and maple syrup and then you cook it for
like 45 minutes
that's a dessert guys that's not a
vegetable that's not a vegetable i hate
to tell you and i know that this is i
know i'm losing
people are bailing because of my views
on this but i
i am unapologetically uh sticking with
this
there's just no way around it few other
people that i want to thank wow the
memberships are exploding let's see if i
can get caught up here
joshua bryant is new member number six
today
chris friedrich is new member number
seven zachariah applebaum
is new member number eight shalom
zechariah
um josh hoagland is new member number
nine
matt beck is number ten and chris
killsdunk
is a number 11 which is a great number
we are standing by for a press
conference
in pennsylvania about voter fraud
donald trump scheduled to be here
cancelled
because someone got the virus we don't
know who and when i say that i'm not
suggesting trump got it as far as we
know trump is immune
uh at least for some period of time
could just be a few months
um but uh he is not going to be here
and we are waiting we are waiting to see
who does show up maybe rudy giuliani we
don't know let's make sure we still have
audio
there we go and we'll check out some
other streams here
um today today begins the process
for the trump okay so there is that
we're just gonna mute that
and keep it live yikes i don't know
what's going on with this feed
oh okay here we go yeah so it's
happening please don't come into the
chat and tell me it's cancelled guys
it's just annoying it's it's a waste of
a chat you know you could tell me
something interesting in the chat
instead you're telling me something that
we are literally watching live has been
canceled it's boring
it's boring we don't like it um okay oh
one other thing i have one other mimetic
element
this is me as david beckham i don't know
how many of you
are familiar with the soccer player
david beckham but take a look at this
look at me bend it bend it like pacman
[Music]
high and tight there
there we go all right so anyway i got
that out of the way for the for the
person who made that
um which which i very much appreciate
and i think with that i'm basically
caught up on all memes
um yeah
i'm caught up on all memes as far as
that goes okay let me do a few twitch
thank yous
thanks to thanks to jbh that's me
fat colonel sanders tiger 40
barons and chess thridius
vanishing tacos all of whom have signed
up
and i very much appreciate that um yeah
the color saturation is
everybody looks trump orange because of
the color saturation on this video feed
that's really weird
this i believe is the pennsylvania state
flag
uh for any of you who were wondering
i know how to get them what's going on
now
the appointed time having come and gone
let's uh ask
our state senators and our state
representatives to join us
today's senate majority policy committee
hearing is the second
of our hearings this year designed to
help us learn more
about the conduct of the 2020 elections
in pennsylvania
what do we need today's hearing was
requested by senator doug mastriano
who in addition to serving the thousand
residents
of the 33rd district in adams cumberland
franklin and york counties
also serves as the chair of the senate's
intergovernmental operations committee
as dr maestriano can attest this subject
is an excellent example not of the
normal layer cake model of
intergovernmental operations but of the
marble cake model
we have examples of local government
county government
state government and federal government
all very much involved in the design and
conduct of an election
and as we've seen not always in a
logical
rational or understanding this is going
to be a mess
i have frequently reminded the students
in the college classes which i have
taught
as well as more recently our own
governor that senators and
representatives and governors are not
kings
we're not judges we're not dictators we
are agents of public opinion
elected by the people for a fixed term
as lawmakers to provide oversight
on behalf of the hell is this over our
government agencies
and of course as lawmakers we're here
today because we have all been receiving
massive numbers
of phone calls and emails and personal
comments when we're out walking our dogs
in our neighborhoods
about the conduct of this election my
office has received a record number of
contacts
over 25 000 phone calls and emails
as of yesterday so what evidence we all
know that pennsylvania's secretary of
the commonwealth changed the guidance
to election officials the day before the
november third election
which added a completely new element of
doubt to our process
issues that should have been resolved by
the legislature
as recommended by supreme court max
justice max baer
were instead carried out by the
secretary without
the approval of the senator the house
this committee held a similar event in
january of 2020
on recent changes to our state's
election laws
at that time the secretary of the
commonwealth assured us
that this process be carried out
smoothly
the large number of complaints which we
have received from our constituents
tells us a very notice there's nothing
in here about
anything suggesting biden didn't win
that's what's notably missing from this
senator mastriano and his staff have
assembled a number of witnesses
who will share their experiences with us
regarding the conduct of this year's
election this should be good i look
forward to listening
to that testimony but before we turn
there i want to introduce
my good friend our caucus administrator
and
as of december 1st our incoming majority
leader
congratulations to kim ward thank you
for joining us
uh please kim they're going to have
witnesses this should be a mess
senator argel and thank you senator
mostriano for inviting me to participate
in what i think is very very important
to the people of pennsylvania
as senator argel has said we have been
inundated with calls and emails and
messages
in our social media people are not
feeling good nor confident about the
process
and the results because of that process
what people the president
and his team deserve this is a president
of the united states
not the president of your middle school
school
work so we need to make sure that they
have the room
that they need to explore every avenue
so when this is over we know that the
process
what worked in it what didn't work in it
and what we need to do to fix it and
what we may need to do
to address it don't we know that this
has been very very
uh exhausting and hard on so many in
pennsylvania
and i look forward to listening to what
the testifiers
and mr giuliani have to say to us thank
you very much again
and um oh my god thank you thank you
master mr senator mastriano
senator thank you kim so rudy's
thank you senator argell and senator
ward thank you for being here and
supporting us here and welcome everybody
to this most
most historic occasion in this most
historic town
exactly 1863. i think today we're going
to see a turning of the tide because
we have not really heard the truth of
the arguments made on the other side of
what happened
and we're dealing with a government and
leadership in harrisburg
that wants to close their ears to what's
happened during this election and sadly
many in the media that are complicit
and want to write off what happened can
you imagine
so for me on this battlefield and
remembering what happened 157 years ago
especially 157 years ago last week where
abraham lincoln gave his most famous
address and i think his
uh rap final sentence captures why we're
here today
he's saying imagine equating this to the
battle of gettysburg
could you i mean what is wrong with
these people for the people shall not
perish from the earth
and everything is at stake in what
happened during this election cycle
everything the republic is at stake this
is no game for us
and for any veteran in this room here
who wore the uniform such as brigadier
general scott perry thank you for being
here sir veterans
put their lives on the line here
fighting for a country and to see
that there is they're acting like biden
didn't win to throw away
our valuable and precious freedoms here
for power
[Music]
you know for me
[Music]
is he going to cry there you go
and uh mr mary's going to be a fantastic
hearing today
mr maybe citizens the governor refuses
to even consider that there is any
shenanigans in the elections here
in our state a state of 13 million
people and he wants a discount because
his guy won
that nothing bad happened and that's
unacceptable if there's any hint of
fraud out there we need to investigate
any governor serving the people this
commonwealth would put aside his petty
politics
would put aside his power the funniest
part is like even though there's no
evidence biden actually lost
pennsylvania even if he did he'd still
be the president let me point out some
hard facts here
we are in adams county named after our
second president
john adams who famously said facts are
stubborn things
[Music]
let me lay out several of these
inconvenient truths as al gore would
have us
think there have been many allegations
of voting law violations across the
state and a governor serving the people
would have to move heaven and earth to
ensure no one was defrauded but yet he's
not moved to action
and even his secretary of state of
course says that there was no
shenanigans of great concern
and i'll remind everyone that i was a no
remember the question is
by this point a month after the election
almost do you have any proof
because sworn affidavits are not proof
more secure than pennsylvania
and she sat there and blinked and
couldn't give me a straight answer
that that elections are more safe and
secure in a war-torn country
devastated by conflict since 1979
what is going on here the place where
this all started in 1776 and we can't
can't get an election right you got to
be kidding me here
and so as a result of her in action the
governor's inaction
is going to look containing the
allegations and to discount the
the very essential freedoms of our
citizens we are here today to try to
find out what the heck happened in the
election
let's find out you know likewise our
attorney general our
senior law enforcement official here you
know instead of being focused on
making sure things are lined up in the
in kosher
kosher don't you dare before one vote
was counted in pennsylvania the day
before the election declared biden the
winner i mean it's there's nothing
to see here could you imagine if the
shoe was up let's see if we can get a
better stream over here that this might
this might be better for us
a lot of problems there and that opened
the door to all the shenanigans and
abuses and folly that we're dealing with
here in the state this day
so what's going on here thousands of
people from across the commonwealth have
reached out to us
tens of thousands uh asking and
demanding action and they deserve it
happen and you're gonna have to decide
good people of pennsylvania
on what happened and whether there's a
strong case we made or not
you know the forgotten men and women are
our great state feel betrayed
by their forgotten men and women i'm
with them i feel the betrayal as well
he's acting like there's dead people on
a battlefield somewhere
and then hopefully had come up with an
approach where that never happens again
and the issues are galore you're going
to hear about poll watchers being denied
access
where election software vendors refuse
to testify before
the general assembly where they got to
hide
do we expect the people to trust their
government and we got to earn their
trust
and this is no game and the very
republic very much is at stake
anyone who loves this country has to put
aside their petty partisan politics and
allow the lights shine
where it is and we're going to find the
truth and celebrate it
you know as a soldier and i was elected
member of the state senate i'm not going
to stand aside and then neither of the
members around me are as well we're
going to fight the good fight for
freedom
quick quick gut check do you guys think
this guy is for real or
that he's just also playing a character
the way these all these republicans are
for power play is unacceptable it's not
going to happen
people clapping oh my god
we do our great men and women in uniform
and those who can lay down
their lives and gain a last full measure
of devotion a great disservice if we
stand aside and allow bureaucrats
and corrupt politicians to steal their
voice
and maybe even steal an election we'll
find out still john eight three
thank you johnny three six six says that
if jesus set you free you're free
there you go we're gonna walk it's not
it's not done it's not a real voter
fraud hearing until religion comes into
it
we choose this day to walk as free men
and women in honor of the sacrifice
not only of jesus on calvary but also in
honor of the sacrifice of brave men and
women in uniform who fought for and
secured our freedoms
we will be relentless in our pursuit of
the transparency of accountability and
truth
the time for dithering politics and
games is over
the time for truth and justice is now in
conclusion
as benjamin franklin is leading
constitutional hall in 1787 he was
approached by mrs powell and this is how
ran up to him we surmised she knew him
personally
and she said well mr franklin what do we
have a monarchy or a republic
and he said a republic if you can keep
it this is our time to keep this
republic
thank you god bless you what a lunatic
thank you
that is weaponized thanks senator
mastrano
oh my god a standing ovation these
people are
sick this is a disease
holy [ __ ]
do they know trump signed off on the
transition like that
are these people even remotely connected
to reality to the
uh introductions of our our house and
senate members
uh let's uh begin with uh our our
representatives here at this end of the
table
gentlemen ladies ah is it on
yeah representative dave zimmerman uh
serving the northeast part of lancaster
county representative greg rothman the
87th district cumberland county
representative mike jones 93rd district
york county
mike jones paul schemmel portions of
franklin county
i like how people are still telling me
this press conference is canceled
representative rob kaufman 89th district
northern franklin county
uh representative stephanie borowitz
from the 76th district
by the way guys please do remember most
jews are overwhelmingly liberal in this
country
i know that in hearing some of the last
names on this panel you might think that
that is different the
the one of the most uh left voting
groups in the country
is jewish americans and they
overwhelmingly rejected trump just as a
reminder
cumberland county and all of fulton
county
you've already met senator kim ward i
believe you know senator master anno
there we go
good afternoon i'm senator mario
scavello from monroe northampton county
and i could see new jersey from my
district
senator mike regan from cumberland and
york county
[Applause]
good afternoon state representative dan
mal welcome to my
91st legislative district
right
representative frank ryan from lebanon
county breakaway program
thank you we are
also uh joined on zoom
senator brooks and senator hutchinson
from northwestern pennsylvania
senator yah from court area senator
stefano
from southwestern pennsylvania from erie
senator martin from lancaster county
senator pittman from indiana county
senator pat brown from the lehigh valley
also
my my job as chairman is to remind our
panelists to keep their microphones
muted
until it is your turn to speak and also
remind everyone to strictly observe
our time limits one other reminder to
our senators and witnesses
at the request of our senate attorneys
this is a legislative
hearing our purpose is to listen to the
complaints of our constituents
government agencies and the need for
possible legislation
we all need to conduct ourselves
accordingly
with that being said uh senator mastrano
i believe you want to introduce our
first witness for 15 minutes oh this
should be great and we will
hold to the representative senator so
you understand
we will hold all of our questions until
the conclusion oh this is rudy isn't it
is this rudy right here i would just
simply say
welcome to america's mayor thank you
mayor giuliani for being yeah that is
him
oh my god this should be an absolute
[ __ ] show
oh rudy's getting a standing ovation
these people are deranged these people
are deranged
what is happening to this country
representatives senator mastroiani
and all the distinguished now it's all
quiet
thank you we are very very honored and
very appreciative that you
are giving us an opportunity to be heard
which we've been denied
almost uniformly by the media
and by uh legislatures elsewhere
all we all we ask is that you listen to
the facts that we're
presenting and then evaluate it um
i can't help but note that we're doing
it here in gettysburg
over 156 years ago the fate of our
country hung in the balance right right
here on this
hollowed ground why can't we see his
face for three
relentless days of bloody close
combat between uh two armies that lost
over 50 000
casualties the fate of our republic was
really
decided that we'd be one nation one
union
one government sharing uh values
that are enormously important to us
right and i don't want to overstate it
but i do believe that those values are
at stake
not only in this election but in the way
this election was conducted
and what we're going to do about it
because if we allow
elections in the future to be conducted
the way this election was conducted
democrats have lost our democracy our
representative democracy
during the course of what a crowd of
lunatics guys this is insane using our
writer free speech
there's been censorship that i've never
seen before
of an incredible nature by big tech
big networks big companies they only
allow
one side to be heard no they don't and
they refuse to allow the other side to
be heard
it's almost as if they're afraid the
american people it's funny it's like if
networks actually were doing the right
thing they would have stopped mentioning
these ridiculous allegations of fraud
two weeks ago the fact that you turn on
any network and they're talking about
the fact that trump still claims he won
they're obviously giving uh an audience
to both sides in which it was done
the most the most dangerous thing is
it is very very similar in at least six
states that we've been
able to study in other words what we're
going to describe to you
with these witnesses happened
in roughly the same way in michigan
wisconsin
nevada arizona and georgia which is
completely out of the purview of the
primary
uh device with a male imbalance
you know there was a fierce debate over
whether we should have
mail-in ballots in the first place no
there wasn't many scholars
many uh experts always felt that mail on
ballots were very
we've had mail-in ballots since at least
world war one there was no debate about
that the debate was
trump didn't want it expanded we were
warned by
justice suiter yeah one side of the
debate we were warned by
president jimmy carter and former
secretary of state james baker
in a report that they did on how to make
elections more secure
they warned us that the one thing to do
is do not go to general mailing voting
because every place it's been used it's
led to tremendous
fraud and that was reiterated believe it
or not in an article in the new york
times
in 2012 an article they have now
forgotten they wrote
that explain the same the same thing
and i think what you're going to find as
you study your mail
in ballot procedure here in the
commonwealth of pennsylvania
and then in the six other places i like
how rudy's acting like this is going to
be a big process of study it's like the
the the electors are finalizing this on
december 14th
that had become pretty expert at voter
fraud
to really go wild
so the
witnesses we present are going to first
show you
that in the case of philadelphia and in
the case of allegheny county i can't
wait to hear from these witnesses the
mail-in ballots that were received
were not inspected at all by any
republican
they were hidden from republicans in the
case of
philadelphia and allegheny county
i can't be absolutely certain right but
i do believe the witnesses will show
that a republican never got to see a
single ballot
he doesn't you know how important that
is to determining whether
it is a valid ballot or not there's only
one time you get to do that
and that's when you separate the
envelope
that possesses the verifying information
from the ballot
pure common the moment you separate them
you can no longer verify
you can't go back and recount you can't
go back and check paper ballot against
the machine ballot because it's a
private ballot
it's an anonymous ballot we want to keep
it that way the only thing that
identifies imagine if they went to their
first witness and it was like hassan
[ __ ] or something like someone who's
just not even participating in this and
is just going to make a mockery of it
inspections have been allowed time
immemorial
in america pennsylvania all over other
49 states
several other witnesses here have been
doing this for 20 or 30 years
they've never heard of a situation in
which the mail-in ballot
was just put in without allowing a
republican the degree
to which these senators including this
guy mastroiano
are just so pleased with themselves that
they're even allowed to be in the
presence of rudy
like they they are just desperate for
this 15 minutes of fame
uniformly not allowed
kept out put in shoot like the other
cows
to keep them away from seeing these
ballots
never happened before not only that
the same thing was done in michigan the
same thing was done in wisconsin and on
and on and on
what's the chance that on the morning of
november 3rd or 4th when they started
the count
that in each one of those places the
democrat leadership
of these highly controlled democrat
cities
that have some history for corruption
and in the case of philadelphia
a long history of voter fraud i could
show you the convictions i don't think i
have to
uh what are they what are the odds that
they're all going to wake up with the
same idea
after years and years have always the
idea of counting ballots as they are
continuing to come in
crazy in a year in which we have a
couple million of them per state
we're not going to allow any republicans
to see them
now the person in philly figures that
out pittsburgh
detroit milwaukee las vegas nevada
or is it more likely that this was a
common plan
right that maybe started out the whole
idea of having male ballots
everybody got together and they were
like listen we're going to have to be
counting ballots as the ballots come in
we're going to count them
and we're going to report them that's
every they conspired
everybody conspired to count and report
votes
you have a much bigger range to do that
so when you hear that testimony about
not being allowed
to see the ballot have to understand
it's much more important than just that
individual
just that individual uh ballot on
election night
when i went to sleep maybe when you did
president trump was leading in your
state by somewhere around 700 to 800
000 votes depending on when you went to
sleep that's a huge number of votes
65 of the vote had been cast under
normal circumstances like if this were a
fair media your state would have been
called for
rudy's about to present explosive
evidence
from the uh the city of honolulu
pennsylvania that will just blow the
roof off of this hearing
that's another battle michigan we were
ahead by 300 000 votes
wisconsin moore georgia we were down to
90
and ahead what are the odds that they
all switched
overnight they just switched
by the next day i think you're going to
see how that
i think you're going to see how that
happened and i think there are a couple
of statistics
that you have to really closely you have
to really closely look at
i'll just mention them and then we'll
move on to the witnesses
i also have munchkins for everybody the
chocolate ones i ate on the way in
but there are some of the jelly filled
and cinnamon sugar that i will be
passing around
into your vote in just allegheny county
and in philadelphia
that were not observed by any single
republican
those ballots could have all been for
joe biden they could have all been for
someone else they could have had no
identifying data they could have been
from the same person
there could have been multiples of them
there could have been no name on them
we have no idea if that's true
and it will be very hard now to kind of
put them together
we could i love how rudy keeps saying
there's a lot of things he's not sure
about
but the witnesses might mention it's
like shouldn't you know exactly what the
witnesses you're bringing are going to
be saying
envelopes be very interesting if they
were kept
and it would be very interesting to see
how many of them weren't filled out but
in any event
under the law of your state which is set
by you
those ballots are illegal uh the judge
mistakenly in his opinion
said that we want to disenfranchise six
million
people we don't want to disenfranchise
anyone
we want to we want to disqualify 682
000 votes so that 74 million people are
not disenfranchised
because that's that's what happened by
the cheating that went on here
i'll give you one other enormously
puzzling
statistic you sent out in the state of
commonwealth of pennsylvania 1823 148
absentee or mail-in ballots i've got a
rudy feed as well
received back 1.4 million approximately
however in the count for president you
counted 2.5 million
by the cheating that went on here i'll
give you one other enormously
puzzling thing
you sent out in the state of
commonwealth of pennsylvania
1823 148
absentee or mail-in ballots
you received back 1.4 million
approximately
however in the count for president you
counted 2.5 million
0.5 million i don't know what accounts
for that 700 000
difference between the number of ballots
you sent out
and the number of ballots that ended up
this is crazy that number
2 589 242
was on your government website until
yesterday
and yesterday it was removed without
explanation
i'm going to be very interested in
hearing what the explanation is
and i can't imagine you could possibly
certify without knowing the explanation
of that
as well as the explanation to the 22
686 mail-in ballots that were returned
why isn't anybody wearing masks like
this is just so stupid
that's a trick how about they were
returned
how about 32 591 were returned
the day after they were mailed another
20 000 were returned
before they were mailed
of course this is only this is i think
this is a kind of a low count
and i guess the crooks in philadelphia
are disappointed in this
they only submitted 8021 ballots from
dead people
right mail-in ballots for dead people
just so you guys know all the i mean
i'm just going to interject here because
what rudy's saying is just it's it's
trash
the whole dead people thing has been
widely investigated and a whole bunch of
the people that they list as
dead voters there's no reason to think
they're dead like there's no obituaries
there's just
you know they they have this these lists
of dead voters a whole bunch of them
it's not clear why anybody would think
they're dead they're just older people
a whole bunch of other cases the people
were called by bbc and they picked up
they were like no i'm alive
i voted i'm alive so a bunch of cases
were
junior senior confusion where the dad
was dead
and incorrectly the junior's vote was
counted as the senior
but there was no double vote it's not
like the kid voted as
the dad and themselves it was just a
clerical error like that it's just
this stuff has been investigated there's
no dead people voting
state's constitution makes it clear who
has the responsibility
for running this election article two
and people are pointing out there were
there was a widow who voted as it was
mrs james blaylock
and they were like oh my god james
blaylock's been dead for 12 years and he
voted and it was like no no i voted i'm
mrs james blaylock
[Applause]
each state shall appoint in such manner
as the legislature thereof the man
redirect
a number of electors it's the state
legislature
that controls this process it's your
power
it's your responsibility and
uh i think you i think you know
and you have to convince the rest of
your members republican and democrat
they owe that to the people of your
state rudy reportedly tapped the
witnesses
mana right before coming out happens
without consequence
if they can just enter 600 000 some odd
mail-in ballots without allowing a
single republican
to to view it what's to say that next
time they won't do a million
or two million i know crooks really well
we know you give them an inch and they
take a mile and you give them a mile and
they take your whole country
so now we'll proceed with the witnesses
let's get to a witness this should be
wild
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much mr
giuliani
i've been informed that we have also
been joined on zoom by senator kristen
phillips hill
uh representative don kiefer we
represented barb gleim from central
pennsylvania
daryl metcalf from butler county and
senator langerhoek
from uh johnstown area uh senator
mastrano would you like to
introduce our next uh panel uh for the
uh uh looks
to me like several people for uh 15
minutes
uh as well this should be wild thank you
senator argo
so uh our witnesses uh come first off at
jenna ellis you have any comments
oh my god jenna ellis is here oh my god
legal legal advisor to president trump
thank you very much
and i'll reserve my comments for the end
and i would just echo
uh everything that the mayor so
eloquently stated thank you
yeah eloquence
this is thank revised list here so we uh
we'd like to call forth uh
justin tweeter from philadelphia justin
all right okay outstanding please my
friend
let's see what he has to say out of
pittsburgh kim are you here
come forth please we have a seat for you
here
where's eric coomer i thought he would
testify
leah hopes where are you leah please
come forth
kayla could you push those two chairs
over thank you and that american flag is
mine if you said it on the table i'd
appreciate it
yeah that's his american flag that's
been laid out there
greg stenchrom from delaware county
you're zooming in i believe
oh he's here yeah of course i met you
come on over brother
could they possibly get worse cameras to
transmit this you can
uh uh among yourselves please
uh divide up the next 15 minutes and
again we'll hold all questions
oh 15 minutes total this should be this
should be rapid fire insanity
i'll start
[Music]
thank you senators and representatives
for inviting me to this important
hearing
my name is justin c quiter k-w-e-d-e-r
i am a resident and registered voter in
the city and county of philadelphia
i'm an attorney i am barred here in the
commonwealth
i am a volunteer certified gop canvas
observer
i was present at the philadelphia
convention center during the pre-canvas
canvas processing and counting of the
ballots
cast in this year's general election i
was first present
as an observer at the convention center
and at the count on election
day i returned as a volunteer observer
to watch the process
every day for the next 10 days i'd
approximate i was there for about 85
hours over those 10 days
part of the reason that i kept going
back was so that i could
authoritatively speak about what i saw
and again thank you for letting me be
here
because what i saw was problematic to
say the least
i can tell you that i am an eyewitness
to many
issues and irregularities that were
observed in philadelphia with the
processing and counting of the vote
i was a witness to too many issues and
irregularities
there were philly cheese steaks served
to the workers but they came in from
jersey it was completely false
advertising personally observe
first the philadelphia board of
elections processed
hundreds of thousands of mail-in ballots
with zero
civilian oversight or observation the
mail-in ballots were handled processed
opened and
counted in hall f of the convention
center
hall f is a vast room approximately 350
feet by 350 feet
that's about 120 000 square feet strong
room the board of elections erected a
fence
approximately 50 feet into the hall that
ran the length of the room
all observers were corralled behind the
fence more than a hundred
board workers were pros workers
processed
and opened mail-in ballots on the other
side of the fence
are these people have these people been
sworn in like is this under oath or not
i think that would be interesting to
know just as a curiosity
of about 10 feet to more than 200 feet
away from us
unlike what some may have reported in
the media the vast majority and i'd
estimate at
it at at least 96 of the board workers
were processing mail-in ballots
15 to 200 plus feet from us
due to the distance of the workers from
the erected fence
was impossible for me or any observer to
see what the workers were doing with any
type of specif
specificity the observers were not able
to challenge
any decision or determination being made
about the processing of these mail-in
ballots
if there's eight people supposed to
share 15 minutes i don't know how the
timing's going to work
opportunity for observers to observe
challenge or inspect the mail-ins being
opened
i find this to be an issue and to be a
regular
it's irregular the second point the pink
highlighted duplicate ballots which i
haven't heard
about at least not in the media as the
weeks progressed the observers were
informed that the board was going to be
duplicating
damaged mail-in ballots that could not
be read by the scanners
i was told that there were more than 5
000 of these damaged ballots
i was also told that the actual number
was unknown and could be much higher
the process for duplicating these
ballots was for two workers to work as a
pair
one worker reading out loud what was
marked on the original damaged ballot
and the second worker using a pink
highlighter to mark the choice on the
duplicate ballot
the board's plan then was to run the
pink highlighted ballots through the
scanners
where they would be counted as votes the
board workers did this pink highlighter
duplication work over the course i don't
think this guy got the message that
all of the people are supposed to speak
for 15 minutes total he's like five
six minutes in and and as people are
pointing out this is not evidence
the pink highlighter could not be read
by the scanners
they all had to be done again all of the
duplicated mail-in ballots had to be
fixed
and the philadelphia board of elections
solution to this problem
was to give the workers who were working
alone individually
stacks of hundreds of what amounted to
blank
mail-in ballots and the workers
individually
were to fill in the correct highlighted
ovals with dark pen
no observation they were marking
thousands of blank mailing ballots
the workers did this double recreation
work for hours before
the observers realized what was going on
because we weren't told what was going
on
only when the observers confronted the
deputy commissioner about this
irregularity was a system set up
where the workers would show the
observers each double recreated mail-in
ballot by flashing the highlighters by
the way were
fuchsia not pink he's lying feet away
for as good as that was
thousands of million ballots were
ultimately counted
in this way again i find this to be an
issue and to be a regular
as senator masteriano recently said how
does he know in such
detail if he was too far to see i i
still am not understanding that
electoral system end quote and let me
add a quote that
philadelphia city commissioner of
elections al schmidt just made
when he said that what he said about
these recent elections in philadelphia
that these were the most secure and
transparent elections in philadelphia's
history
end quote now
i wasn't around for every election in
philadelphia's history but i can tell
you as an eyewitness
for 10 days for more than 80 hours
what i saw was not a secure and
transparent election
there are major concerns about the
legitimacy of hundreds of thousands of
ballots that were counted
in philadelphia
now someone's coughing and nobody's
wearing masks this
may i suggest to you that any
restoration of faith on the part of
pennsylvanians
in our electoral system can and will
only be accomplished
after an investigation into this crazy
how a guy who was
unable to observe the election has 15
minutes of observations about the
election down to detail
properly applied in the next election is
in my opinion my opinion unacceptable
the issues irregularities and
illegitimacy of what i saw leads me to
conclude that the laws of the
commonwealth
and of the united states were not being
followed in philadelphia
when hundreds of thousands of ballots
were counted in this year's general
election
action must be taken now to maintain our
free and fair elections
and to preserve and protect our
elections integrity
i look forward to answering any
questions that you may have thank you
how does everybody else speak within the
15 minutes good afternoon
my name is kim peterson and i appreciate
that i'm here today thank you all for
having me here today
i'm from pittsburgh pennsylvania and i
am here to tell you what i witnessed as
a canvasser
where the warehouse where they open the
mail and ballots
and separate them from the envelopes as
we've been discussing okay
as the afternoon of election day i
went to the um down to the warehouse to
be a canvasser to as a republican
representative
to be able to watch them open the mail
and ballots and
as the gentleman justin just described
um we as i was led back to the area
where we were able to view
them opening the mail-in ballots we were
kept in a corral
um that was at least 15 to 20 feet
they were corralled with steer and hogs
people opening the balance there were
people that were you know 50
100 feet from us um the closest that was
20 feet about
and you could not see at all the
envelope the ballot itself
um what where they were stacking them
anything
that was required that we were able to
be able to see
um there were also monitors up around
the area the monitors were
pathetic to be honest um you they were
fuzzy
looked like they were using old
technology as far as
i mean we have the most clearest gordon
willis reportedly the director of
photography
and managing the lighting here we're you
know
probably from the 60s you're looking at
all these
multiple cameras screenshots
put together of people opening ballots
but
you could not even see at all um
or witness anything if anything was any
misdoing or anything going wrong
it was very discouraging on my part um i
was very much looking guys she was
discouraged that probably means biden
lost
representing representing um myself
and pennsylvanians um in a fair election
and i was um i guess discouraged about
it i love this country and i love
pennsylvania um
i was not born and raised in
pennsylvania but i have been here for
30 years and um it
it is very important to me that this
election be fair
and um thank you again for having me
our pleasure
[Applause]
first and foremost excuse me my name is
leah hoops i'm from delaware county
pennsylvania
i was a poll watcher on the day of
election
and i was also present at the counting
center in chester pennsylvania
so first and foremost thank you to this
committee and all those involved
and especially senator mastriano and
former mayor rudy giuliani
to our fearless and brave president
thank you for being our shield and
putting us first and i am forever
grateful
our shield it is an absolute honor trump
really shielded us from the virus didn't
he opportunity to speak about what took
place in delaware county pennsylvania
i feel as an american that is my duty to
help protect the integrity of our
elections
not just for me but for every american
there are many who have lost life and
limb for my right to vote
i want to give a brief introduction in
history of how i got involved in this
election
four years ago donald trump came down an
escalator and i knew that he was here to
take back our country
i was born and raised in delaware county
in a conservative home
i was taught from an early age to love
thy neighbor defend your country and by
all means always speak the truth
i took those values throughout my life
and applied them in every avenue
possible
which brings me up to the present and
about 18 months ago
i became a volunteer and assisted with a
campaign for a magisterial judge
in that process i was approached by my
current chairman imagine being given 15
minutes for eight people to speak you're
supposed to point out the irregularities
and you go into your life's history of
involvement in politics
it's like what did you see lady during
this time i started a watchdog group
and reached out to the thomas more
society now associates we've been
focusing our
our efforts in election integrity our
greatest efforts have been following
closely the newly elected and completely
democrat-run
delaware county council and the democrat
majority election board
this also includes any and all
contractors support staff and any key
players involved
what we found was actually concerning
not only was private grant money used
for
from the center for tech and life owned
by google and mark zuckerberg
the pop-up voter sites were also
approved these pop-up voter sites were
placed in heavily democrat cities
including chester and upper darby
pennsylvania
in which case the grant money from the
ctcl was used to pay for electioneering
it was literally a one-stop shop walk in
apply get your ballots
i'm sure this is an intro and they'll
get to the proof of fraud
soon maybe i don't know different areas
let's also make note that the voting
machine warehouse supervisor
is a bernie sanders delegate who was
also solely responsible for every
scanner
machine vcard and all machines with
absolutely zero
experiences so they they actually
allowed democrats to be involved that's
shocking
oh my god
[Music]
it's lo-fi static
give her three microphones oh my god
why would they even change the mic this
is just a
this is just a trick
[Music]
okay sorry um
sorry i forgot where i was okay so the
real story uh
is the 2.1 million dollars spent
to move the counting center from the
courthouse in media pennsylvania
can you imagine she was making such
little sense someone just took the
microphone away
let me explain to you the layout of the
counting center it is in the middle of a
huge parking lot
which sits back on seaport drive next to
loading docks
it has multi-million dollar connections
to the company power hrg
and subaru park soccer stadium the
county center was on the first floor in
which there were multiple places
to bring in ballots in and out of
elevators and many rooms
in which workers had access i was there
for three straight days
what became of concern was the back room
which had no observers
she saw ballots being replaced with
swordfish down at the docks it was crazy
no cooperation complete resistance from
election
night and every day after it took until
our lawyer got an injunction to get into
that back room in which pre-canvassing
was transpiring even with an injunction
which was a joke
we were granted five minutes every two
hours
and the setup was sitting in a chair 20
feet from any physical ballot
i truly wish i had enough time today to
recreate what i witnessed and felt
during those moments but we did not
gather here today just for me and my
experience but rather a collection good
point yes
glad to recognize americans like myself
what i hope to achieve is for the public
to understand is what we
is that we have stuck our necks out have
been intimidated
threatened bullied have spent countless
hours away from our families
friends and jobs we have signed
affidavits under penalty of perjury
which should be consideration enough to
know that this is a very serious issue
i'm here for one thing only and that is
to speak the truth
this is not about party this is about my
country
every american deserves transparency
truth and be able to question those in
power without fear of intimidation
bullying or backlash i hope this
committee takes action if needed and
justice will be swift to anyone involved
in fraudulent activity
the republic is angry disgruntled tired
beaten up and ready to defend this
country
this is sad
thank you without election integrity we
are just another banana republic
i thank you again for your time efforts
and service
and it is an honor to be here and to be
part of a historical moment
thank you what's it's historically
stupid
a historical moment
it's a tough group to follow my name is
gregory stenstrom i'm from delaware
county
oh boy i'm a father a family man
i was a former commanding officer and
executive officer in the navy
i'm a veteran of foreign wars i'm the
ceo of my own private company
i'm a data scientist i'm a forensic
computer scientist i'm an expert in
security and fraud
uh leah had recruited me for this
election
um and uh i was glad i uh thank you for
that
so what great fortune that she recruited
a data science expert
in advance of an election they now claim
is fraudulent another
former us marine officer and uh the two
of us were the only
gop poll watchers in the city of chester
which is about 40 000 people uh
because of the consolidation for covid
uh there were seven polls we were
allowed you know that we were able to
make it to in 22 precincts
what we saw out there was pretty orderly
um
and uh exciting people were excited
about uh one of the things we saw
out in the field was that people quite a
few people had
done mail in ballast so they came in and
they hadn't
been updated in the delaware county
database yet so they would come in and
say
i you know the database is not showing
me on the database i'd like to vote
so the process uh one of the processes
was to
give them a provisional ballot
and uh and then they would vote
provisionally and then later on their
vote would be
sorted out um that didn't happen uh
i i observed and the gentleman that was
with me observed
uh seven different polls where uh
the people were given a regular ballot
so they cast a vote and put it in
you know we let it happen a few times
you know we didn't jump all over them
you know
happened a couple of times we went up uh
in all cases the election judges were
very uh
forthcoming um very polite they
apologized and they said they couldn't
do it
but that uh somewhat spurred they
couldn't do what was like what
this guy's not even being clear in his
story who said that who couldn't do what
building not much around it and i wanted
to take a look
all day long i had been told that um
there were 10 to 20
gop poll watchers down there and that
everything was well in hand and out of
curiosity i decided to go down
i arrived at six o'clock um with four
other
gentlemen uh again foreign military and
some good citizens from the former
military okay and um
we weren't allowed to get in until uh 11
o'clock at night and we had to get some
um
legal help to get us so it took five
hours to get upstairs
um after that um you know what we saw
here is uh what i
was i really think the the crux of this
in delaware county
is uh as an expert in this i think it's
impossible
to verify the validity of about a
hundred and
hundred thousand to a hundred and twenty
thousand votes
now delaware county's got 425 000
registered voters
approximately 300 000 of them voted i
don't know what the exact number ended
up
uh mayor giuliani had nailed that number
but of that number uh over a hundred
thousand are in question
in my mind what i saw as a forensics
expert was an election process
that was forensically destructive right
in the manner it was conducted
with the envelopes being separated from
the ballots and gone to the other side
of the room
the problem with that from being
forensically destructive is that when
you go to do a recount
okay the machines did a pretty good job
of recounting so if i have 120 000
ballots mail-in ballots at one side of
the room
and envelopes at the other side of the
room is still going to come out 102 000
votes for
president uh vice president uh biden and
18
000 votes are you guys getting this i
don't care how many times you recount
those votes
you know the ballot's going to come out
the same every time so the notion of a
recount
in a forensically destructive process is
is uh doesn't work very well
what we saw there what i saw there was a
chain of custody in all cases that was
broken
it was broken for the mail-in ballots
the dropbox palace
the election day usb card flash drives
in all cases
the chain of custody and the procedures
that were defined by the delaware county
board of elections
and election process review were all
they didn't follow one
i i couldn't even redline this
multi-page document because the entire
document
would be uh well he couldn't redline it
because he didn't have a red marker
so i personally observed um usbv cards
being uploaded to voting machines by the
uh
the voting machine warehouse supervisor
on multiple occasions
i saw this personally i brought it to
the attention of the deputy
sheriff who was there stationed who was
a senior law enforcement officer
he brought usbv cards to the sheriff
this was during the five hours when he
couldn't get into some building
it is not being observed he's not part
of the process that i can see
and he's walking in with baggies which
we have pictures of and
bags in our affidavits and he was
sticking these
usbs into the machines
so i personally witnessed over that that
happened
24 times over 24 times wow
um we have multiple other witnesses to
start including democrat poll watchers
oh my god
and we were told i was told the next day
uh
by uh the uh solicitors uh
well actually not the solicitor but the
attorney that we had secured
that they said every election they leave
a couple of usbs
in the voting machines and they're
brought back and generally the warehouse
manager comes over and puts them in
okay so in talking to the us
attorney general uh mcswain and other
law enforcement officers i found out
that was not the case
that generally uh you know more than
more than two is
unusual so they denied they did it
but um as of today 47 usb cards are
missing
and they're nowhere to be found so i was
told personally
that these 32 these 24 to 30 cards that
were uploaded
um weren't there those cards uh i
demanded
that the uh they didn't update the vote
live time you
this guy's really blowing this whole
voter fraud thing wide open
i don't i don't know how joe biden's
going to be able to survive this
what the what what the result was and it
was uh
50 000 votes
and i think as a computer scientist an
american and a patriot
right it doesn't matter who those 50 000
votes were
i'll tell you they were for vice
president biden but
what was shocking to me as an american
as someone wait now are these fifty
thousand part of the hundred and twenty
thousand he says he knows about or is
this a separate fifty thousand
happen so several other things that uh
came up was on thursday it took us three
days for them to obey the court order
that i secured with leah's help and the
help of the thomas moore society
uh who we thank uh incredibly uh
good patriots they they got us in there
they got the order for us to get in and
watched it uh look at the
back offices which were locked uh for
five minutes every two hours i went and
i was the first one allowed to go in
despite this guy's claims for being a
forensic data scientist and an expert in
all these different things
why do i have the feeling this is the
type of guy who would email me through
my website and say
they think zuckerberg censored me
because they were watching me on youtube
and twitter kicked them out
with 70 000 unopened mail-in ballots
they were in boxes of 500 stacked in
neatly the gentleman that came in with
me
is it was a democrat poll watcher
is a forensic pathologist a very
detailed very dedicated man and he took
meticulous notes as well
and i verified with him are you seeing
what i'm seeing
we both agreed as gop poll watchers and
a democrat poll watcher
that we had uh witnessed 70 60 to 70 000
we had a little bit of a disagreement
there
the problem with that was by that time
the mailing ballots had already been
counted
wait so are is this 60 to 70 000
now different from the 50 000 he just
talked about from the usbs
question is where the 70 000 ballots go
and nobody knows we have a picture in
here
of a large number of boxes that i took
that were filled with what appeared to
be ballots
sitting by the blue crest machine they
were there for about three hours and
then they disappeared
i found it notable when i watched it the
first one they were taking the ballots
up and down
i said i am an expert in fraud i saw the
balance he's been expediting
multiple elevators and iraq and i think
a lot of well-meaning people and a lot
of honest people were there
doing that they were trying to
participate in the process
and i would say that uh 99 percent of
the people there
the way the process was designed i
believe
that people thought it was a
non-fraudulent process
i heard that said many times i was uh
you know i said there's no fraud going
on here i said well i'm not
you know i didn't even bring that up but
i think people
saw what they wanted to see and they saw
what was intended for them to see
i called it at one point kabuki theater
i said it was all designed this is a
boston guy right it was entertaining
there were cameras on it
when we finally got into the back room
where the boats were being ingested
as a data scientist i want to see where
where the data's coming in
and i wanted to know the universe of the
votes well the universe of the vote is
supposed to be 120 000 mail in ballots
we were told there were six thousand
ballots remaining
so i said okay we have a universe of 126
000 votes
and then when i get back there the
universe wasn't 126 000 votes
the universe was 200 000 votes
so are the 50 60 70
and 120 000 votes part of the 200 000.
uh i was only manned by one person you
know people ask me all the time how do
people commit crimes
um i know there's a lot of theories here
and i always look for the simplest thing
people have stuff that you know sticking
usb sticks in
putting ballast in very simple things
people were told to bend over and cough
to ensure they were not occulting a usb
v drive
tory words and uh you know like fraud
and so forth
as a forensic computer scientist my
interest is in
the data where did it go computer
science
oh my god how did the data come in and
go out of the system
so i think as a scientist we need to
look at that we need to audit that
what was really upsetting to me the most
upsetting was i had
spoke to multiple law enforcement
agencies and
literally begged multiple law
enforcement agencies to say go in
he was begging in order to prove you
know prove that nothing's happening
you neither exonerate yourselves in the
process or refute what i'm saying
please it's very simple process
just go get the forensic evidence from
the computers
it's a simple process you take that you
turn the computer off
it's non-destructive takes moments maybe
half an hour
20 minutes it takes a half hour to turn
the computer off now
you open the computer up you take a a
device called a bit blocker
you put it in the hard drive it's done
under the observation of law enforcement
officers
they take a forensic image of the drive
put it all back together
it wouldn't have taken more than an hour
to to image all
five machines i guarantee you no one in
this room is even vaccinated against
usbv
despite my objections and that was three
weeks ago
lastly when they said they said well
we've got all the forensic records and
so forth
we just learned two days ago that
virtually all
chain of custody logs records
yellow sheets everything
was gone all forensic evidence all
custody seats
in delaware county are gone
they had a signing party where they sat
down and
and poll workers were invited back to
recreate those logs he also saw people
in the back pouring blue label on
hard drives and lighting them on fire so
we have a situation where
we have a hundred thousand ballots to
120
000 ballots both mailing and usb they're
in question
now there's no cure for this there's no
remedy for this
as a home is a home charter we can we
could have a re-election in delaware
county for our own representatives
within our own town but there is no cure
for that for the president of the united
states does anybody understand
if the votes were on a usb drive a usbv
drive in one envelope two envelopes
and whether they were filled out with
black or pink highlighter
and whether they were on pink or yellow
or white paper
were so you know had done things follow
their own procedures which they created
almost unilaterally
we would be in a situation where they
could exonerate themselves
and they could say mr spencer you've
been misinformed
we have evidence about which of the 100
things you said
but that's not the case they can't do
that so i say if you can't certify that
vote
and you can't certify a hundred thousand
votes out of three hundred thousand
and you can't certify delaware county
and i'm done and thank you for your time
and patience
i like how people in the crowd claim to
understand it thank you all
[Applause]
to this panel before i have senator
mastrano
introduce the next 15-minute panel i
want to note that we've also been joined
on zoom by representative kathy rapp
from northwestern pennsylvania doug
thank you panelists
if you can stay in the area we're going
to bring up the next group here we're
going to say questions and answers
before the end
mr mayor i understand my list might not
be synchronized i'm going to ask you to
introduce the next folks coming up yeah
let's hear from rudy on the list
if you could pass the mic to the mayor
somebody everybody talking to the lawyer
there's no masks talk right into it
[Music]
four more witnesses like this or we
could now put on the
statistical expert who could explain
some of this
and then put on the additional one
either way you prefer
okay we can't hear anybody
all right guys i think we've probably
had enough of this
i'm gonna wrap i've got some cooking to
do for thanksgiving and and that type of
thing i really appreciate you guys
joining me for this completely
cartoonish farce
um we are going to be bringing you all
of the important events over the next
month and a half
including the georgia senate debates
georgia senate results the inauguration
maybe at some point some kind of a press
conference from donald trump if he ever
takes questions again
and in order to be notified of that make
sure if you're watching on youtube right
now you hit that subscribe button
it's completely free i'm selling you
nothing just hit that subscribe button
if you're watching on twitch please make
sure to follow us we're two thirds of
the way to our first
100 000 twitch
followers i hope everybody if you're
doing anything for thanksgiving i hope
it's great
remember if you add brown sugar and
maple syrup to sweet potatoes it's no
longer a vegetable
it becomes a dessert don't let anybody
tell you otherwise
and i'll see everybody again very very
soon